truth who was the last person you made
out with and how long ago it was last
night
okay hey Christine on out her sweet
tooth nice to meet you I'm 25 I'm from
Santa Monica I was born in Tokyo Japan
and I am 27 years old I'm feeling
excited but also nervous and I don't
know what I'm in store for I'm feeling
not as cool cuz I wasn't born in Japan
which is pretty awesome Santa Monica's
pretty cool let's do it let's play some
games truth or dare
I'm gonna go with truth what is a
physical trait of mine that you like
your eyes have very beautiful eyes
yeah the color everything truth or dare
truth all right what was your first
impression of me first impression oh I
definitely saw your tattoos I was like
yeah this guy he's a little wild
truth or dare dare I was the first one
first there I dare you to do oh this is
a good one
do ten push-ups shirtless amazing how
does that little workout it was okay
yeah a little parched truth or dare
I'm gonna go with the truth okay truth
who was the last person you made out
with and how long ago was that it was
last night okay it was a first date
mm-hmm with someone I met on dating out
he how'd it go it was actually honestly
and the badly we were on the same
wavelength nice nice truth or dare -
dare I dare you to what get pied in the
face with whipped cream all right I
a plates full of whipping cream ready to
pie Carlos this is like one of those
things you're just supposed to like
[Laughter]
delicious how's that that's not the
reduced fat there might be you know I
will do a deer tail okay I dare you to
stare at me for 30 seconds forehead to
forehead okay honey it actually feels
kind of good because his forehead is
really soft I've never heard that before
and that is the most epic compliment
ever I think that was pretty intimate
yeah
over head to forehead in a good yeah it
worked out truth or dare
Oh dare I dare you to hug me for a whole
minute absolutely good over here ain't
holding your breath you know I can't
hear your heartbeat I don't have one
theoretically this should have been a
minute by now okay yeah all right that
was cool yeah it's less awkward than the
face-to-face I think it's cuz we've
already done that now so it's not that
weird but like initially a hug is like
you hug people all the time you never
just like come here yeah that's never
how you say hello to people truth or
dare truth
mm-hm if you could change one thing
about yourself what would it be and why
I wish I was taller I wish I was like
six feet how tall are you for stuff I am
five three I wmba really like towering
over what people ask you to get things
on the top shelf well I don't want to do
that that's what you would change it is
your height yes it stretch yourself okay
it elongated yourself and eventually
you'll grow this is the end of the game
I guess we're done all right this was
nice I felt like we know each other a
little bit more than you probably would
have on a regular date that's all yours
yesterday and this is gonna cool I feel
like people should do this more often I
think so too
cards around right all right well this
is amazing
take care
[Music]